[Music]
I'm Angela and I'm CR and we create
videos on YouTube about our crazy big
family did y'all think when you saw that
we were hiking near water that someone
was bound to fall in so did I and guess
what I'm glad you have it happened JJ
come here he is now carrying his shoes
with his pants rolled up you think it to
give you a ticket II know it's crazy in
bed we have seven kids for now and five
of them are adopted two of them are
biological we've kind of adopted from
multiple different ways international
domestic embryo so embryo adoption is
basically where I carried a baby that
was not genetically ours it's an embryo
that's created in an IVF lab and I gave
birth to them with those same hand
motions ah we are gonna go get some
blood sugar tests done they're a little
low we're gonna get him back up to
stable all right so we've been down at
the the nursery for a couple hours now
and glucose levels came back over the
benchmark where they needed to be so
they are gonna get the girls ready to go
and we were gonna come back down to see
a very anxious mother so good news they
made it back
got a happy mama rare so oh wait she has
like had her eyes open but he is
starting too can you get a picture of
her away over here I can't wait you know
for us embryo adoption was kind of there
were two reasons why that was very
appealing to us one was that we were
struggling with secondary infertility
and we were unable to conceive on our
own and the second piece of that is that
there are hundreds of thousands of
embryos on ice and so being able to sort
of add to our family that way by giving
these embryos a chance at life instead
of being you know frozen indefinitely or
discarded or destroyed seems like a
really amazing option to us and there
was this I mean truth be told there was
a want to be pregnant again actually we
talked about you know standard adoptions
or you know going that route again but I
think I think it's a great option for
somebody who really desires to carry a
baby and perhaps because of infertility
reasons can't can't conceive on their
own involuntary birthing coming from my
wife that's pretty impressive
involuntary when you're pregnant
sometimes things just happen it just
comes out so if you wanted to do an
embryo adoption the first thing you
would probably want to do is get in
touch with your local fertility clinic
um because again it's very similar to
the IVF process as far as like setup
goes and having tests done and
everything and then you have to go
through the process of matching your
family to an embryo basically so that
can be done there's so many different
ways there's so many different outlets
out third-party agencies and things that
will match you and then once you are
matched then you go through basically an
embryo transfer just like a couple going
through IVF would you go in
an old turkey baster yeah take a really
long thing that's what she said and they
place the embryo or embryos inside your
womb your lady business put the oven
later they're talking to each other in
their own language Angela I think
they're planning something oh man down
no easy for me to say don't be afraid
because I'm on the other end of it I
understand there's so many fears when it
comes to just adoption in general but
embryo adoption too because it's so
foreign to most people they think
they're like wait a minute wait you
carried this baby but it's not
genetically your child like that can
feel really weird but on the other end
of it it's so incredible and amazing and
we look at these babies and feel like
they belong in our family they fit here
it's a beautiful and amazing thing and I
know some people probably would worry
about well would I love the child like I
would a biological child and for us
that's never that's been an easy
question to answer for us I guess my
advice would be just because it's
different
and maybe hard doesn't mean it's bad
watching these two little ones grow now
it's like the thoughts don't ever cross
my mind that we don't have the same
right you know you know I mean it's like
dude these are our cards yes our other
kids recognize them as siblings it's
like yeah seamless
[Music]